pues es un día muy contradictorio mire
en este momento es tan sola las calles
usted ve detrás de mí estuvo un viernes
como hoy estarían absolutamente llenas
estamos en toques de que daniela por el
cover 19 pero también no lamentamos es
pintamos es seguridad para proteger esta
caravana del papá francisco las las
calles están repletas del ejército de
todos estos diferentes cuerpos de la
seguridad pero cuando se terminó aquella
misa en aquella catedral mucha gente
salió a la calle caminando especialmente
los cristianos que habitan mucho en esta
área estamos muy cerca de allí y todos
iban con una sonrisa era era muy
emocionante era era realmente como un
momento de tranquilidad de hermandad no
caminaban cristianos y musulmanes el
papá alcanzó a pasar por ejemplo por el
hospital cristiano de bagdad donde se
atendió a muchísima gente durante la
guerra ya en ese momento sonaba el
cántico de la llamada a la oración en el
minarete que queda al lado así que fue
una tarde realmente muy bonita muchos
en irak nunca pensaron que el papá
realmente fuera a lograr llegar a este
país ya había lo había intentado antes
por cuestiones de seguridad por
cuestiones de pandemia y así que verlo
aterrizar verlo moverse por estas calles
ver ser reunido con no solamente con el
presidente al primer ministro sino
también con todas las autoridades de la
iglesia en irak pues ha sido un momento
muy muy muy importante para este país